okay everyone let's welcome our next
speaker our next speaker
is and he is a senior research scientist
at The Institute for disease modeling
and he'll be talking to us about Cyrus
simplifying scientific software in pipon
take your away please all right thank
you na um all right well hello everyone
uh thank you for being here this morning
um so how many of you are are from New
York and how many of you traveled out of
state probably the rest of you just
checking your
working so I want I did anyone do an
land acknowledgement this morning no um
anyway I just want to acknowledge we are
on the na land um so all of us even
those of us who are from New York are
still visitors on the land so I just
wanted to you know acknowledge the
ancestral owners of this land and if you
want to learn some of the na work
there's a link in the slides to do that
oh if you do want to follow along or
click on anything the link is hi data
2023 cis.org
okay so just a just a brief bio um I
started out Life as a neuroscientist and
a physicist uh so I did things like
trying to teach robots to pick up
balls um and this is uh doing was neural
network modeling but very different than
what we now think of as neural Network
modeling this is like modeling actual
neurons and trying to get them to um to
learn in biologically realistic ways um
uh in the since uh since I did that work
of course um uh neuronal networks have
become extremely popular um and
non-biological Landing rules have um
have proven to be to be very successful
but maybe maybe at some point biological
ones will come
back um but about halfway through my
Neuroscience career I got interested in
epidemiology as well um and so I started
working on public health um so we uh we
were working on a number of different
diseases um mainly HIV um and we were
working with a lot of countries around
the world trying to help governments
plan their HIV um responses so how much
testing should you do how much treatment
should you do um so we would build
mathematical models we uh put in all the
data that we had available and then we
would use that to determine like what
the optimal way of allocating limited
resources were um and when I say data uh
you you know probably a lot of you are
familiar with like machine learning and
Ai and stuff like that so you're
thinking like megabytes gigabytes
terabytes like if there's like one
survey every five years and so you have
three data points that was amazing we
loved it when we had that much data one
data point that was a little hard to did
a trend line too but three data points
amazing so very different scale than uh
than what you usually think of when you
think of as
data um so I wanted to um give a sort of
brief brief overview of some some
questions about Cyrus so how many of you
would identify as
scientists couple a couple people how
many of you identify as
Engineers how many of you don't identify
as as
either few people okay
so Cyrus is uh is intended primarily for
scientific workflow and I'll talk a bit
more about what I see as the differences
between a scientific workflow and an
engineering
workflow um but ultimately there's a lot
of stuff that happens in in science um
that's just kind of annoying you just
have to do it you have to do it over and
over again um and it can get really
annoying um and so the point of Cyrus is
basically to help with those
things um and there isn't really a
unifying theme uh so because science is
messy Cyrus is uh kind of messy um
because science is messy Cyrus is Messy
as well um there all these things in
terms of like loading data and looking
for numbers and arrays and plotting and
so forth and it's just there's a lot to
do um and so the idea of Cyrus is to
make each of those things a little
simpler but because of this there's no
there's no learning curve so the whole
Cyrus package is pretty big but each
part of it is completely independent you
can use Cyrus to do your parallelization
and if you're doing plotting in SE one
you're 100% welcome to you know keep
using SE one for everything there's no
ecosystem that you're either in or out
um you can just uh use it as a dropin
replacement uh anywhere you need
it um and so what I'm trying to say is
there isn't really a killer feature but
if there if I had to pick one my
personal favorite is this thing called
an obct which is for an object
dictionary um and basically the idea is
it gives you the best of all worlds
between a Python dictionary a python
object a data frame like thing arrays
like you you name it if you can think it
it can do it not not quite but we'll
we'll get to that in a
minute um so that my for the talk um
I'll talk about the motivation we had
for developing Cyrus uh some of the
design principles behind it um a couple
vignettes illustrating how it's been
used in the real world quick summary of
like pros and cons um and then if we
have time I'll go through a quick um a
quick
demo so as I said before scientists
usually are not the same as Engineers
they have different ways of thinking
they have different ways of doing things
um you know engineer want the same
answer every single time they want you
know systems that are really robust they
don't care if it takes a little longer
to code up the first time as long as it
always works um scientists aren't like
that at all you know often with science
to spend like three years collecting
your three data points or something like
that you know great expense and personal
trauma don't worry I have a therapist so
it's okay um so and then what you do
then is you just write a ton of like
these really crappy scripts to plot your
data analyze this it's like uh I think
that's an outlier but I'm not sure let
me try deleting it and then like rewind
my analysis and and see what happens so
it's a very different kind of mindset
than engineering where you know you have
like input something reproducible output
yes we do want science to be
reproducible but it tends to be a much
Messier process much more much more of a
Sausage Factory than a a car factory um
and a lot of scientists don't understand
the the code they use I I want to give a
little anecdote here um which is um I
have a have a colleague who I noticed
he's an art programmer um and uh he was
you know trying to use pipelin and I
noticed like his daily commits like
increased by a factor of 10 like it was
just insane um and I also noticed that
they weren't making any sense um and so
and so I I said like hey what do you
like what what happened it's like you're
writing so much more code now and he's
like dude I have to tell you there's
this thing called Chach PT it's amazing
you just ask anything and it will give
you code and so he would do things like
py he would type in Python how to remove
outliers and it would give code and he
would literally copy and paste that into
his analysis script but he had no idea
what he was doing because he was like
it's python it's you know I don't
understand it it's you know not like on
line r function that I I know so I'm
just there's this Oracle that gives me
the answer and so I'm just going to I'm
just going to do it um and
so it's for the scientific audience it's
really important to have that kind of
Simplicity I think a big reason why R is
so popular among biologists and
bioinformaticians and people like that
is because a lot of the analysis you can
do in just a single line um I personally
hate art I think it's an incredibly ugly
language but I do appreciate
that if you can do something in one line
it makes the science part really
clear um and so what you get with this
kind of system is you get lots of
imperfect uh reinventions of the wheels
so you know everyone's going to remove
outliers in a different way someone's
going to be like oh I have some I'm
missing some data I'm going to remove
like nans and then a nun appears and
then all of their code crashes and they
have no idea why because they didn't
even know what a n was um and so there
uh I think there's a lot of value in
having something uh where instead of
having these scientists with very little
engineering background reinvent the
wheels there's kind of a nice set of
these wheels um already made for
them um and the other thing is even
though yes nulear power plants were
originally invented by scientists
they're not built by scientists they're
built by Engineers um and so this is
kind of a this is another key difference
between science and engineering which is
that you know if if there's a mistake in
your code and you're a scientist then
you know figure six of your paper in the
international Journal of you know
whatever is going to look slightly weird
and probably no one will ever read that
paper and it's not a big deal um if
you're an engineer and do that you know
if you're working on Google
infrastructure and you know you make a
typo then Gmail goes down and you have 5
billion people mad at you so it's just a
different it's just a different scope
it's a different uh mindset
um so a few of the Cyrus uh design
principles um so one is to have simple
interfaces um so for example if you want
to parallelize something again it's a
it's a single line now as I saw from the
RS of hands most of you are Engineers so
you're probably looking at this thing
and it's like well that's that's totally
simple with concurrent futures. process
pool executor executor app execut map
yeah okay like once you know what it is
it's fine
but if you're if you're an R user whose
only link to python is via chat GPT like
you're not going to think like I need to
paralyze something concurrent Futures
like that's just never going to occur to
you um and relatedly um there's uh uh
there's this idea of dejaron ification
so the Cyrus version is not actually
much shorter than the than the NPI
version but again uh remember what I
said about um you know about just having
having correctly invented wheels so
there's actually a typo in this that I
didn't even notice until after I had I
had made the slide can anyone see what
it is it works but but it's it's could
cause
problems
ARR so so data is an array Val is a is a
value
so the typo is that it should be NP do
apps because ABS will convert the entire
array to uh python data types and then
have to and then have to convert it back
um so um so this can you know if you
have a really big array this can be like
10 times slower or or even more um but
then when I tried to fix this I was like
oh EMP arrays have a DOT ABS method
right like surely they do
no they don't damn it so even for
something as simple as this oh and then
this is this is on me I can't blame
numpy or anything for it but when I
originally did this I did Arc sort data
minus valid I was like this doesn't look
right why does this not look right oh
yeah that's right not what nearest
means um so again this another another
idea is in terms of exception control so
python is and rightfully so um very
insistent that if anything goes wrong
it's going to like just barf immediately
it's like you craft an exception just
like you know stop um and even even
handling exceptions there's no way um to
handle an exception in one line you need
you need four lines at minimum try thing
accept pass there's no you know it's not
like you know if and you know you don't
have to do if blah and then else pass
but python makes you be really explic
expit about you know are you absolutely
sure you want to catch this exception
and that's the right decision for python
but if you're a scientist then sometimes
you know that your data is crap and
things are going to crash um and so Cy
gives you a way to uh be a little more
flexible in terms of in terms of
handling those
exceptions um and lastly despite all the
limitations of of science it is
important uh that it is reproducible so
by default um most Cyrus objects when
you save them or if you use a Cyrus
function to save um it will store the
versions and get info and working a get
repository and so forth in the object
itself um so here's a here's what I
would consider a kind of typical um
scientific script so let's just um
Define this like random wave generator
so it's pretty simple we just make a
sine wave add a little bit of noise to
it nothing nothing too complicated so so
this is how so let's say we want to like
save this data we've generated um and
then and then plot it as a like 3D 3D
kind of thing so we have to import a few
helper libraries because python doesn't
do a lot on its
own um so let's start timing let's see
how long these simulations take to run
Let's uh run it in
parallel um and now let's save it to
save the data we've calculated to files
this is a little messy because um we
uh we want to zip them so they're
smaller but um you know but then we want
to sa them as a pickle of course in this
example we could just say it as a you
know as a data frame or CSV or something
but I'll I'll show other examples where
where that wouldn't
work um so now let's let's load the file
we have to like undo everything we did
loading the zip file and then the
pickle and now let's plot just a bunch
of code in order to make a plot um and
then let's see how long it took and then
yay we get a plot at the end so it's not
it's not too bad you probably look at
this code and it's like oh that's
nothing I write like 10,000 lines of
code a day like this isn't a problem but
with Cyrus it looks like
this so you actually get a 75% less code
in order to get exactly the same result
um and the the important thing here is
it is exactly the same as old like a lot
of Cyrus fun are you know pretty simple
wrappers on numpy and rapot lib
functions um but it's just um it's just
there are a lot of common tasks like
timing things saving data plotting um so
you can uh so s will simplify those
kinds of things so if we if we go back
here we can see that for timing there's
just a there's a timer and you can use
it very simply just as like start stop
but you can also like do do math on it
you can do multiple timers you can use
it as a as a context block and things
like that for parallelization um again
it's all it's all built in and we'll do
another example where it saves you even
more time um you want to save something
you can just do do save um so that's
that's really nice again this is you
know not assuming that you have to like
make a Harden system for billions of
users but you just want to save some
random numbers security is not really an
issue for that
um and same same with loading um and
then like I don't know I don't know why
when you try to like plot something in
3D with numai you have to be so explicit
about every single thing it's like if I
don't specify X and Y I probably just
want it to be a range so just you know
give me that
range uh so the second example I want to
give is a is a real world example so um
as I mentioned I'm an epidemiologist um
and I happened to make the switch fully
into epidemiology um just a few months
before Co started uh so when it did
start um I uh I started building this
model called
coin um so we built it with a large team
of about 50 people um uh some some
Engineers but mostly scientists and and
public health officials um and in
contrast to most of the other Co models
that were around it was both open source
and in uh your
python um and so the other thing the
other thing about scientists compared to
Engineers is we're really slow it's like
hey can you build this thing it's like
yeah I need five
years um and of course Co wasn't going
to a wait for us to do that so a model
development process that uh would
normally take a few years we basically
had to do in days um so the first um so
we started seriously working on this
model um in like the first week of March
and then by uh the 12th of March the
governor of Washington state was using a
projections to decide what to do for the
for the 5 million people who who live
there so that's a lot of pressure that's
getting uncomfortably close to the to
the nuclear power plant
example um and this is what the what the
code looks like and I showed this just
because it's kind of a similar design
philosophy to Cyrus uh so this is a
simul
um showing uh where you set up set up
the model with a bunch of different
parameters um and then you define in
this case you're defining a bunch of
different interventions so you're
looking at school closures um a lockdown
order partial reopening and then
implementing testing and contact tracing
um interventions um and the model will
predict what will happen to your Trends
in this simulated population of 200,000
agents um and so what was um what was
Innovative about this is that um there
were other models that could produce
similar things but either they were
super super slow to run um so this is
all built on built on nump and Numba
under the hood so either they were super
slow to run um or they took like
literally 10 times as much code in order
to um get to the same thing and again
this is about putting the science first
um you maybe can't show like a
politician like this this code but you
could definitely show one of the
politicians advisors this code and they
can be like oh yeah I I get I get what
that means I get that um you know if you
if you say um you know 0.7 means that
you're expecting you know Mobility to be
reduced by 30% to you know to7 so they
can just look at the code and it and it
makes sense to them and needless to say
km is built on cus side of the hood and
that's why we were one of the reasons we
were able to build it so
quickly um we also also we also built a
web app um uh there are now many tools
for for building nice web apps so the
web app is also uh based on Cyrus but
you know as you as you've seen you there
are lots of other uh choices now but we
were able to get this up in roughly a
day which we were which we were pretty
happy
about um and uh so it was pretty
successful in terms of in terms of
uptake especially for this type of type
of model that ended up having quite a
bit of policy impact
okay so just to just to summarize here's
kind of the the structure of Cyrus um so
there are um again science is messy
Cyrus is kind of messy um and there you
know lots of different aspects which it
can which it can help with and we do
have a bit of time for for demo so I'll
I'll run through
that um there are some limitations of
Cyrus um so there are opinionated
defaults and of course opinions may vary
uh if you disagree with the default and
Cyrus then it can be a hindrance rather
than a
help um so again Cyrus prioritizes
flexibility um and there's a trade-off
between flexibility and robustness and
security so again if you need something
super high security you probably don't
want something that's going to be like
ah this list of numbers looks like an
array I'm just going to make it an array
you probably you probably don't want
that um and related to that um you know
it is suitable for most scientific
projects where the stack is very limited
usually it's like data analysis script
you're done uh you know it's a very
different system if you know your
component needs to play nicely with you
know hundreds or thousands of other
components in in
ecosystem um and I put this in here
before I saw the show of hands and saw
that so many of you Engineers um I bet a
lot of you do like Ty hints who likes Ty
hints damn it
all right well I don't like tys I'm like
you're using python just it's fine
python will figure it out so so Cyrus is
kind of an extension of that uh you know
even even
further um there are docs online docs.
cis.org and it was also recently
published uh in uh the Journal of Open
Source software and I don't see Thomas
here but um he's one of the reviewers I
he's been involved in P data New York
um and I wanted to thank the uh
contributors um and of course if you uh
if you want to uh you can get in
touch all right so um there is a there
is a demo I'll pause I'll pause here if
there are any questions um you can
follow along in the demo if you want um
or um or just watch watch
me um I'll do it on a codes basis
um but if you want to you can just go
here and I think you should it should be
enabled by default but if you click on
code then you should be able to go on
code spaces and start up a new
instance yes so um one thing that I
thought was kind interesting to person
the part anything to minimize L PL is
that something that you can use like
kind as a component on its own right
yeah yeah for sure and I'll I'll give
some examples of that of that
here okay a quick show of hands for the
light or dark theme who likes
dark who likes light I'm sorry light I'm
sorry light
people um okay so um to install of
course it's on on pip um you just do pip
install um and then while it's already
it's already installed but assuming you
have a scientific you know setup already
like you know Mt potet pandas and things
like that um it only it only requires a
couple other
packages um let's let's import some
libraries this is pandas which is taking
a long time not Cyrus don't don't blame
don't blame that um so let's uh let's
start with some some stuff so let's just
make some data some random
numbers um and let's let's try to find
the values that are greater than than
0.9 so of course we can do this without
Cyrus and it's not that big of a deal uh
you know it's again not particularly
intuitive but it's not a lot of it's not
a lot of extra
code um and so with Cyrus again it's a
very very similar kind of thing um this
also has um has another shows another
function called uh string join which
again if you want to like join a bunch
of stuff you you know they not that many
different ways that you want to that
you'll want to do it so it's just a bit
clunky to you know have to type that
over and over and over and over again um
and then sometimes it's like well what
if you know you're already in an S
string but then what if you want to do
something with a dictionary but and
there are like these other quotes in
there and you can end up with like six
levels of nested quotes and it's it's
not a lot of
fun um so this is um so this is to show
the the
obct I um so by default it displays in
kind of a more Rose um output than a
normal dictionary and the key the key
feature of an of this kind of uh
dictionary is that you can access
elements in three different ways um so
you can use you can use a standard
dictionary notation so just data uh do
data with the um with the brackets you
can also use dot notation um or you can
treat it as if it were a list uh and and
call it by by index and so this can be
really useful um if for example you're
storing a bunch of scenarios um which is
something that happens to us all the
time it's like you know Baseline school
closures things like that and then
sometimes you want to access that by the
key so you want to say like data school
closures and then but sometimes you're
just like well I don't want to type all
of that every single time I know it's
like element three and then you can just
do do data three um uh by default again
this comes back to the the idea that
Cyrus is intended for more scientific
workflows um by default if you use slice
notation on it um it will it will it
will assume it's it will assume its
numeric data cast it to an array and
then you can just treat it treat it as
an
array um and also has a bunch of other
um uh methods uh so for example um again
you could do enumerate and then you know
do whatever you need to do with
parentheses and get that to work but
it's such a common task that you can
also just enumerate the items uh
directly
um so let's let's create some
data um so we're just creating a range
of dates we're creating a r some random
numbers with the same length as the
dates um and again we can plot it
without Cyrus that part is fine and
you've probably seen lots of plots plots
like this um it's clear where the
outliers are less clear Where the dates
are um if you don't look closely it kind
of looks like the like the y axis is 0
to 6ish instead of actually in the
millions so with Cyrus it's it's pretty
similar um but I'll go through a few of
these
examples um so firstly um there are
built-in defaults if we're running in
Jupiter so that will change the back end
that's uh being used um so if you can
see
see how this is much lower resolution
and then in with the Cyrus version it's
much higher resolution of course you can
do that yourself it's just it's just
more
effort um so again we can uh there's a
there's a Cyrus data frame that W wraps
a pandas data frame uh and makes it a
little bit more convenient to to do
certain tasks um and there are tutorials
on each of these things um so if you
want to know any more detail you can go
into that um but I think the main thing
here is there's this date format thing
so if uh if your if your access is dates
again I'm not quite sure why this is the
default doesn't really seem ideal for
for anyone um but Cyrus will give you a
much more human readable version of the
date AIS you can also do other things so
comatic will again by default um look at
your y- axis and convert it to sort of
what we think of the standard numbers
rather than the default um we can do box
off if any of you came from M uh mat lab
that's a that's a function that you
might be familiar with um and we can
also just automatically choose limits
for our y
AIS um okay for so for saving and
loading again the example I showed
before was just numbers and it's like
why to use a CSV and this is why you
don't use a CSV um so a lot of a lot of
the code that I write at least uh looks
kind of like this so we might have a
class uh we might want to simulate
something this is just simulating some
random walks so uh not super interesting
um I will just show that uh Cyrus does
come with some Styles as well that you
can use um but so what's really cool
here is we can just save this thing it
uses um pickle or Dill um and then we
can save any arbitrary python object and
what that means is that we can load it
again and get the exact same thing back
um and then we have a complete copy of
that object so we can you know keep
using it and rerun it as if it were
new um so here's a slightly more
advanced parallelization example um so
let's say that uh we have this other
function that generates some random
numbers
um and now this is how you would have to
parallelize it uh uh normally so you
have to parse the arguments uh and then
and then run it with this um so with
Cyrus what you can do instead is it will
automatically interpret any keyword
arguments as keywords for the functions
so instead of these 10 lines you can
just do it with a single line
instead and then we can
and um and so then just lastly um I said
I'd show you how to make that graph um
so you there's some smoothing functions
here uh you can time it uh you can plot
in single line uh with 3D um and then
you can save it and then you get that um
all right I will I will stop there um so
uh yeah happy to happy to take any
questions
[Applause]
for um the num itus have representation
num oh so so you're asking if Cyrus has
a representation of numai or if it's
using it
directly yeah um so it just it just uses
it directly um so so a lot of Cyrus
functions are just um are just graphers
for the for the nump functions um so one
case uh so one case in which this uh
wouldn't work is if um you do want to do
something like you know compile you know
compile with torch or compile with
number or something um in that case
you're better off you know doing that
doing that directly but otherwise the
cus functions just use um use n High
directly
yeah uh I work with epidemiologist too
and there's definitely a preference for
R and watching this it seems like it's a
response or uh to the Tidy verse uh
where you know trying to bring someone
over from R to python we'll say like oh
but I just have this set of packages and
it's all organized and clean and then
you know I'm trying to teach the python
it's like oh wait you also have to
install you also have to install pandas
and three right thiss response to typers
that that's an excellent point I didn't
I didn't mention that but that's that is
exactly right um this is you know you
could you could say this is a tidy verse
for for Python and as much as I as much
as it pains me to say it tidy verse is a
really good
idea let's thank our
speaker